[Musique]
ces plastiques edge à montréal on
fabrique des tuyaux des châssis des bacs
de rangement même des pièces de
véhicules
[Musique]
bref tout ce qui est fait plastique peu
importe la couleur la grosseur ou la
fonction horreurs de la guerre
depuis deux ans l'entreprise sert aussi
de salle de classe à des élèves du cégep
de tête paul aujourd'hui ces quatre
étudiants en plasturgie assiste un cours
en usine sur le séchage des pièces de
plastique
le surfeur pour le taux d'humidité
grâce au projet pilote auquel participe
le premier du genre au québec
ces étudiants reçoivent la moitié de
leur formation en milieu de travail
une approche directement inspirée du
modèle allemand
[Musique]
mais
en juillet 2016 le premier ministre
philippe couillard visitait la
multinationale semaine il à munich
alors on s'est mis d'accord qu'on ferait
ensemble un projet d'information dual ou
l'enseignement en milieu de travail est
une tradition bien établie
sadate vraiment du moyen âge si vous
voulez parce qu'il y avait une
organisation des artisans dans des
corporations où ils ont aussi fait la
formation de leurs jeunes
l'entreprise accueille dans ses
académies à travers le pays
plus de 9000 étudiants dans une foule de
domaines techniques
pendant trois ans les étudiants
apprennent un métier essentiellement en
entreprise et sont payés pour le faire
mais dans ce système là vous avez la
combinaison entre un sujet théorie et
après vous pouvez directement vos
entraînés ont réalisé ce que vous avez
appris justement le modèle a fait ses
preuves au fil du temps et contribué au
succès de l'économie allemande qui
demeure à ce jour le moteur de la
croissance européenne
cette formation-là a fait en sorte à ce
que l'allemagne a produit beaucoup
beaucoup de techniciens de très très
haute spécialisation et de très haute
qualité
forçant fonctionne un certain temps que
le plastique swatch et un certain temps
pour former des techniciens qualifiés
prêt à occuper un emploi au sein de
l'industrie
c'est aussi l'objectif du cégep de tête
feuilles de thé la première séance et
plus haut niveau de l'observation grâce
au projet pilote les élèves passent la
moitié du temps en classe
l'autre moitié en milieu de travail ça
va graduellement jusqu'à une autonomie
quasi complets
que ce soit en recherche et
développement en conception ou en
production de pièces de plastique
les étudiants travaillent sur de vrais
projets ya le côté théorique téléphone
après
plus les tarifs dans l'entreprise puis
titre un réseau de contacts apprend à
travailler tu vois vraiment du concret
mais souvent c'est par le professeur qui
vous expliquent la théorie c'est
vraiment un autre cas de la chope que
vous et spéculateurs et d'une autre
manière c'est qu'un mode de vision
différente une vision différente dont
bénéficie aussi les enseignants par les
sorties qu'on fait ça nous permet même
au corps enseignant comme pas grave
d'être en contact avec les entreprises
et en entreprise
et puis je me suis
leurs besoins et leurs attentes au
niveau du menton contrairement à la
pratique allemande
ici ce sont les enseignants qui donnent
la formation en entreprise
autre différence les étudiants ici ne
sont pas payés pendant leurs études
sauf durant leur stage d'été les mêmes
sans salaire tous sont très motivés il
faut pas passer à l'ennemi de quelques
souvenirs et à montréal a ajouté revenus
pour le cours qui ont jamais été un
record ayant toujours été à l'heure du
pôle un absent c'est très très positif
aussi parce que les étudiants
masculins voit le concret ils sont déjà
dans dans des vrais vrai projet il y a
aussi des avantages pour les entreprises
karl d'astous a été embauché comme
mécanicien chez plasticage il profite de
ce matin du passage des étudiants et de
leurs enseignants pour parfaire ses
connaissances en plasturgie
ça nous aide à comprendre la marche en
commun fonctionnent mais le plus gros
avantage dans un contexte de pénurie de
main d'oeuvre c'est la possibilité de
recruter de nouveaux employés
déjà habitué au travail en usine on
espère que avec ce lien qu'on fait avec
yvon est intéressé à revenir nous voir
d'un énorme d'orsay vevo et à en croire
les résultats obtenus par les premiers
élèves avoir participé au projet pilote
le modèle allemand chose qui me croisent
pas de belle amie fanny nos finissants
qui vont terminer dans quelques jours
chacun a déjà eu près de 15 offres
d'emploi donc ses propos déjà qu'un oui
chacun aujourd'hui
avec quel sujet
et c'est l'une des choses aussi vraiment
motivant le moins de vous dire lâchez
pas on a vraiment besoin de la relève
[Musique]